Klar, jetzt bin ich auch so...
Mit einem Namen schilder gemacht, weil es nicht mehr weiss, wer wir sind. Alles klar. Ja, okay. Erstmal herzlich willkommen zur hundertsten Folge des Podcast-UFO. Wahnsinn. Ja. Und wir haben einen fantastischen Gast, wir dachten, das klappt nie, aber wir haben uns endlich getraut zu fragen und es hat sofort geklappt, ihr hört seine Stimme, es ist Jan Böhmermann war. Hallo. Herzlich willkommen. Hey, willkommen im Podcast-UFO. Zum allerersten Mal hundert Folgen schon. Hundert Folgen. Wir haben uns 99 Folgen über Wasser gehalten, einfach mit der Aussicht, bei Folge 100 kommt gleich ja.
Das gibt es doch gar nicht, ihr macht schon 100 Folgen?
Ja, da sind wir wirklich durchgezogen.
Da draußen ist Moslem vor dem Fenster.
Oh, das ist Moslem im Regen.
Man weiß nicht genau, das will er uns mit.
Mitarbeiter von uns.
Ja, 100 Folgen sind schon gewesen, wir ziehen heute noch mal so ein bisschen Resümee, gucken zurück, hundert Folgen. Wie war es für dich, was sind so deine Top 60 Podcast-UFO-Folgen? Ich fand die Folgen mit Luke Mockritsch super, die habe ich gerne gehört. Die hast du gehört, erzähl dich. Hast du die wirklich gehört? Natürlich gehört, fast alle Folgen. Ich meine, ich arbeite ja nur dreiviertel Stunde in der Woche und da habe ich natürlich viel Tagesfreizeit und die Serien sind auch schnell durchgeguckt und da habe ich mich total gefreut dass ich das podcast ufo für mich entdeckt auch bei spotify meinem großen brust die mich quasi nähert du hast auch gemerkt was du für eine macht hast du musst etwas erwähnen im podcast bei spotify einfach und dann rufen die an und fragen dann ob der podcast da auch laufen will wirklich nachdem wir uns erwähnt hast haben die uns sofort angerufen und gesagt wollt ihr auch bei uns laufen uns laufen. Ja, willkommen bei Spotify Podcast Ufo, vielleicht erwähnen wir euch noch mal ein bisschen öfter, aber das ist richtig geil. Wenn er macht, dann ist einfach Verzweiflung, kann auch Verzweiflung bei den anderen sein. Nee, das ist ganz geil. Worum geht es jetzt eigentlich, also wann wird das ausgestrahlt, wann wird es gesendet? Also das ist ein Podcast, das ist im Internet und das wird am Montag veröffentlicht. Das heißt, heute ist Donnerstag, dazwischen kann es noch sehr viel passieren. Genau, ja. Wir unterhalten uns jetzt aber über Dinge, die zeitlos sind. Richtig, wir unterhalten uns hauptsächlich über die Evolutionstheorie und alles, was da auch ansteht. Heissluftballons. Wie funktionieren sie? Was ist los? Wie kann das sein, dass Luft fliegt? Heisse Luft. Das ist Wahnsinn, oder? Es ist unglaublich. Hat eine geringere Dichte als kalte Luft. Die Luftatome, die Luftteilchen, das dehnt sich aus und es wird dann dadurch leichter, weil also quasi weniger Teilchen auf gleichem Raum und deswegen steigt das Ganze. Aber wie kann Heißluftballons steuern? Warum landet man nicht irgendwo? Aber es gibt auch so Touren, die man buchen kann. Und landet man dann irgendwo? Nein, Heißluftballons können nicht gelenkt werden, da musst du tatsächlich mit dem Wind fliegen. Und dann wo landet man denn dann? Wo gerade platzend ist? In irgendeinem Wald, oder was? Auf einem Feld natürlich, aber das ist tatsächlich wirklich wahr. Heißluftballons, und es ist auch windstill in Heißluftballons, weil du mit dem Wind fährst, man sagt, fahren. Aber man kann ja auch Sachen aus dem Heißluftballon werfen, um sozusagen die Richtung ein bisschen zu färgen., und Sandsäcke, um die Höhe. Wenn du nach links wirfst, dann wirst du nach rechts. Du kannst nur die Höhe und du kannst dann quasi die verschiedenen Luftschichten mit verschiedenen warmer Luft. Und wenn du nach oben steigst und da ist irgendeine Strömung, wo du weißt, da geht es nach links oder rechts, dann kannst du da quasi hoch und runter steigen. Und damit kannst du so ein bisschen die Richtung beeinflussen, aber eigentlich kannst du den nicht lenken. Ah, das ist genial. Das ist so ein bisschen wie diese Physikaufgabe in der Schule, wo du in einem Einkaufswagen sitzt mit ganz vielen Ziegelsteinen und dann wirfst du die Ziegelsteine aus dem Einkaufswagen und dann bewegt sich der Einkaufswagen. Das war genial. Was war deine Note dabei? Zwei. Oder die Frage, die ich mir immer stelle in Fahrstühlen, wenn man runterfährt und der Fahrstuhl stürzt jetzt ab und man kurz vor Aufschlag einfach nach oben springt, ob man den Aufsprung dann, ob man das... Oder bei Leitern, wenn ein Leiter umfällt, wenn man dann abspringt, dann ist man noch plus minus null. Wenn die Leiter einfach runterklettert, während sie umfällt, dann kommt man am Boden wieder an. Ja, das ist ja klar, aber bei einem Flugzeug zum Beispiel könnte man, wenn ein Flugzeug abstürzt, rechtzeitig, bevor man den Boden auf sich zukommen sieht, das müsste man ja hinbekommen mit dem Timing einigermaßen, wenn man einfach kräftig nach oben springt, ob man das dann schafft, dass man nicht zerquetscht wird. Aber ich glaube, da müsste man mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit nach oben springen, mit der man gerade nach unten fällt, Und das kriegt der Mensch glaube ich nicht hin. Aber ich stelle mir das Fernsehinterview vor, wenn dann die Reporter an einem Wrack ankommen, hunderte tote Leichen und eine Person einfach so, ja, ich bin einfach im letzten Moment abgesprungen, kein Problem, hier lebe ich. Ich verstehe nicht, warum nicht, also wenn man Platz ist für eine Warnbässe unterm Sitz, warum man da nicht einfach ein Fallschirm auch einfach darunter macht. Zu teuer. Und dann einfach so 800 Leute aus einer A380 einfach so langsam. Ne, es ist zu teuer. Ganz klar, zu teuer und zu riskant. Ja, aber ich stelle es mir cool vor, so ein cooles Bild. Dann haben auch Flugzeugabstüsse noch mehr Schauwert. Aber überleg doch mal, und ich glaube auch bei so grossen Flugzeugen, wenn die abstürzen, hast du nicht mehr die Zeit davor, rauszuspringen. Mir hat mal ein befreundeter Pilot gesagt, es stelle sich als einen sehr schönen Tod vor, abzustürzen mit einem Flugzeug, weil es geht sehr schnell. Also es sei denn, du bist jetzt ein technischer Defekt und es trudelt, aber das passiert ja meistens nicht. Entweder reißt die Kabine in zwei, weil eine Bombe explodiert, das geht dann aber bis sofort bewusstlos und bis sofort fällt es dann einfach bewusstlos runter, kriegst du das alles gar nicht mehr mit. Oder halt, na gut, schlimm ist natürlich dieses Germanwings-Ding, wo du wirklich weißt, das passiert jetzt gleich und du da mehrere Minuten drauf hin, das ist natürlich schrecklich. Aber da nützt es dir einen Fallschirm ja auch nicht, du kannst die Tür ja nicht aufmachen von innen. Aber wie beruhigend ist es, mit dem Piloten befreundet zu sein? Sehr beruhigend. Echt? Also jetzt ist hier jetzt nicht einer, den wir auch kennen, der Pilot, sondern hier in der Firma gibt es einen richtigen Pilot, der auch Verkehrspilot ist. Der hat früher beim Radio gearbeitet und der hat immer davon erzählt, dass die da wohl lernen, irgendwie in der Verkehrspilotenschule, was dann wohl passiert, wenn keiner die Kabine einen Leck hat, elf Kilometer in der Höhe, dass der Druckabfall dann so schlagartig ist, dann nützen auch die Sauerstoffmasken nichts mehr. Da bist du sofort bewusstlos, wenigstens. Da gibt es dieses Bit von Bill Burr, wo wir waren, der war in Köln, hat er gespielt, sein Stand-up-Special, und der hat erzählt, dass er mit dem Piloten befreundet ist und der hat gesagt, immer wenn ein Flugzeug landet und dann wieder startet, dann kommt danach immer so eine ganz entspannte Durchsage, so ja, gar nichts passiert, wir hatten einfach keine Landererlaubnis so richtig, aber in Wahrheit war einfach richtig Action im Cockpit, weil da einfach massive Probleme waren, da waren einfach ein anderes Flugzeug und es werden fast tausende Menschen ums Leben gekommen, aber die bleiben danach einfach ganz ruhig, weil die auch keine Panik verbreiten wollen. Das heißt, wenn das richtig scheiße ist, dann erfährt man das auch nie als Passagier. Ein Schulfon von mir wollte Pilot werden und hat dann auch die ganze Pilotenausbildung gemacht und so, da muss man ja mega krass sein und irgendwie ganz viele Sachen gleichzeitig machen können. Und dann hat er in so einem Simulator das Flugzeug abgestürzt und dann hat er gesagt, er konnte danach nie wieder in so einem Flugzeugsimulator irgendwas mit irgendwas mit Flugzeugen zu tun. Nie wieder mit seiner Freundin schlafen. Ja, genau, nie wieder Smarties essen. Aber er war einfach so, dass er, weil er das schon mal in einem Videospiel erlebt hat, da dachte er, das geht nicht. Allein die Möglichkeit, es schon mal virtuell erlebt zu haben, war so schlimm, dass er gesagt hat, er kann mit dem Wissen nicht in den Flugzeug steigen. Aber dann soll er sich vielleicht einen anderen Job suchen. Ja, das ist ja gut. Man muss da einfach ausblenden können, die Piloten müssen diese allgegenwärtige Gefahr ausblenden können. Ich rufe ihn an, du hast völlig recht. Das ist ja bei uns auch so im Showgeschäft, man muss diese allgegenwärtige Gefahr, die der Job mit sich bringt, die muss man ausblenden können, sonst kann es sich nicht machen, dann bist du nervös, verspannt und das ist bei Flugzeugpiloten natürlich sofort auch Menschenleben gefährdet. Ganz anders als wir gerade, wir sind nicht nervös und verspannt, gar nicht. Genau. Wir haben uns auch gerade gefragt, warum setzt man sich immer so Extremsituationen aus? Also gerade auch du wahrscheinlich als jemand, der immer vor Publikum geht, das ist ja schon immer eine Situation, die so ein bisschen Adrenalinschübe befördert. Warum macht man das? Warum nicht einfach chillen? Das ist einfach, weil man im Leben, man möchte einfach den Kick haben. Man will den Kick haben. Das ist für euch ein Trill. Ja, wie könnte man keine Mammuts mehr jagen und irgendwoher muss man das Adrenalin bekommen.
Das stimmt schon irgendwie. Aber warum machen das dann nicht alle?
Ja, ich meine,
das Level ist ja verschieden. Einige Leute
kickt es ja irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mal rechts zu überholen.
Das ist geil. Andere Leute
kickt es halt, sowas zu machen.
Aber macht man das
für das Adrenalin? Ich glaube eher nicht.
Nee. Anerkennung.
Warum macht ihr das denn eigentlich? Anerkennung. Für die Anerkennung? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Liebe. Es ist immer, alle Menschen machen alles, das ist die grosse These, die ich aufstelle, jedes Mal. Wow, das ist die grosse These. Das ist die grosse These. Alle machen alles für Anerkennung. Ja gut, irgendwer muss es ja immer sagen. Ja, oder für Lia, für Liebe. Das kann ja gut sein. Für Likes, für Instagram-Stories. Es geht doch alles nur um die Likes, genau. Ja, ich habe jetzt Instagram-Stories für mich entdeckt, aber ich merke schon langsam, dass ich auch nicht mehr mitkomme mit dem Trend. Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, ob du da schon mit dabei bist. Ich habe Instagram-Stories auch für mich entdeckt, aber hauptsächlich die von anderen Leuten. Ich folge Lars Eidinger, Lena May, Landruth und Larissa Ries. Genau, und Larissa Ries hat mich darauf gebracht, dass es eine gute Idee ist. Die hat letztens nicht nur gezeigt, was ihr Hund für tolle Kunststücke kann und wie sie aussieht, sondern hat auch immer so, wurde
angegrapscht, glaube ich, im Club. Ja, genau, ein grosses
Feminismus der beide geführt. Da habe ich das erste Mal bei Instagram
Stories ein kleines Tränchen
Erfahrung, die ich
wahrscheinlich nie machen werde, angegrapscht
im Club und deswegen war es mal schön, sich da mal
reinzuversetzen, quasi über Instagram Stories
reinversetzen zu können. Ich könnte mal ganz kurz
mal die von Larissa anmachen, oder ist das
Urheberrechtlich schwierig?
Ich glaube nicht. Schauen wir mal her.
Super, Wilma! Wilma hat den Zahnstocher gefunden. Fein, Wilma, super! So, und jetzt kommt Max mit dem Rissig-Stocherbaum. Noch ein Hund. Hat sie noch einen Hund? Ich finde es unfassbar verwirrend, weil bei mir war es so, ich habe mir Instagram-Stories angeguckt und dann dachte ich mir immer so, die habe ich doch gerade schon gesehen, die Instagram-Story und immer wieder die gleichen, jetzt ist Larissa schon wieder bei einem Dönerladen und immer dasselbe. Und dann habe ich gemerkt, dass du bei Instagram-Stories ja entweder nach rechts tippen kannst für die nächste oder nach links tippen für die letzte. Und ich hatte meinen Finger so auf dem Mittelding und habe immer nach vorne und hinten und bin immer so hin und her gewandt. Einen Tag lang. Gut, vielleicht ist es auch einfach nicht für mich. Grosses Problem für mich bei Instagram ist, dass wenn man auf ein Bild ranzoomen möchte und einfach doppelklickt, instinktiv, weil es überall ist, man sofort ein Herz verleiht. Und eigentlich möchte ich nur gucken, ob man irgendwie Nippel sieht oder sowas oder wie die Visage von der Person. Aber machst du es dann wieder weg? Weil ich habe dann immer Angst, da steht dann bestimmt, ja, wenn man gefällt das und dann guckt man nach und dann ist es nicht.
Aber bei Twitter ist die große Frage, weil es ist ja von
dann, man kriegt ja dann doppelte Aufmerksamkeit
dann, die Person weiß, er hat geliked und er hat dann
nochmal bewusst, das ist fast schlimmer
als nicht zu liken, ist den Like nochmal zurückzuziehen,
weil man bewusst die Entscheidung getroffen hat,
nein, dich möchte ich nicht unterstützen.
Paulina sehe ich hier auch gerade die
man kann ranzoomen, ja man muss das
aber mit beiden Fingern, man kann das so pinchen. Paulina ist ein echter Instagram-Star und ich hatte es glaube ich hier auch gerade, man kann ranzoomen, man muss das aber mit beiden Fingern machen, man kann das so pinchen. Palina ist ein echter Instagram-Star und ich habe es, glaube ich, dadurch auch geschafft, ernstzunehmende Schauspielerin zu werden, beziehungsweise ernstzunehmend zu werden für Casting-Agenturen, weil die gucken immer vermehrt in letzter Zeit darauf, wie viele Likes hat man, wie viele Follower bei Instagram und das ist dann irgendwann schon echt ein Faktor, weil Palina, wie viele Leute hat die denn die ihr Follower? Ich habe Millionen, oder? Auf jeden Fall mehr als mehr. Das ist halt so cool. Ich glaube, die machen das oft auch einfach, weil die halt nicht so viel Content brauchen. Ich meine, das geht ja nur zehn Sekunden oder so. Die kriegt man mal schnell voll. Da hat man mal eine Idee, die so lange trägt. Paulina, 820.000. Wie viel habe ich denn eigentlich? Ich weiß es nicht. Aber du machst keine Instagram-Sorys, ist Twitter das letzte Medium, das du bespielst? Also Twitter, nee, Twitter ist, ich bin ja jetzt 36, bin jetzt in einem Alter, wo man sich
schon so langsam setteln muss, auch so,
welches soziale Netzwerk man gerne nutzt. Und ich finde, das ist
eigentlich für mich das perfekte Medium.
Es ist für mich so eine Mischung aus Tagebuch führen
und Notizbuch,
manchmal auch einfach, um Witze festzuhalten
oder weil ich weiß, die nächste Sendung ist am Donnerstag
und wir haben jetzt keine Ahnung, Freitag danach
und der Witz, den ich jetzt gerade
im Kopf habe, der ist nächste Woche nicht mehr aktuell, dann haue ich jetzt einfach da raus. Das ist für mich das perfekte Medium, das ist genau das Richtige. Du bist eher so ein, Florentin, du bist gar nicht so ein aktiver Typ eigentlich. Nee, gar nicht mehr, mittlerweile nicht mehr so. Also bei mir ist es tatsächlich so, wenn ich jetzt bei Gute Arbeit bin und da meine Gags raushauen kann, dann sammle ich eher alles dafür, als dass ich die schon bei Twitter raushauen kann. Ich finde es lustig, sein großes Comeback war zum ESC, davor war halt lange gar nichts, und am ESC war auch kein Gag, er hat sich einfach nur beschwert, dass ein Beitrag plötzlich in 4 zu 3 lief. Das war einfach eine technische Beschwerde, das ist ein Problem, wenn man dann... Er wird zu so einem Wutbürger. Ja, wenn die Leute erwarten, dass man nur Gags macht, dann fällt sowas auch unter, man dann einfach so, ich habe Probleme mit dem Handyvertrag und alle, ah lol, lustig, ah, und du so, nee, ich brauche wirklich Hilfe, Leute. Ich stelle mich wirklich, dass es 4 zu 3 ist, was bei dir. Ey, ich, aber ich fantasiere auch manchmal, ich weiß nicht, ob du auch manchmal von Amokläufen fantasierst, wenn du ICE bist oder so. Also, dass nicht du selber Amok läufst, aber was passieren würde, wenn jemand jetzt Amok laufen würde? Im ICE wäre es eine relativ dumme Idee, im ICE Amok zu laufen. Und dann überlege ich mir immer, hat man dann die Verpflichtung, das zu twittern, wenn das jetzt passiert, hat man dann zu sagen, hey Leute, ich bin jetzt der Erste und dann kann man nämlich den Hashtag festlegen. Weil irgendjemand muss den Hashtag festlegen für so eine eigene... Ganz tief schwarze, zynische Gedanken, die du da machst. Das kann niemand unterstützen. Das ist einfach zu sehr im Internetabhängungsflow und du musst mal raus. Ja, ich muss mal raus, zum Erste. Du bist jetzt auf die 30 zu. Ja, das stimmt. Aber wo soll ich hin? Wo soll ich hingehen? Was soll ich draußen machen?
Was bietet mir die Außenwelt?
Die Frage ist, was willst du eigentlich,
Martin, wo willst du eigentlich hin?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Wo willst du eigentlich hin?
Ist das eine Zwischenstation?
Wirst du eines Tages vielleicht dann doch Chemiker?
Ist das so eine Sache, wo du dich
nochmal komplett in eine neue Richtung
entwickelst oder irgendwann zeckst du dich vielleicht doch
an das Showgeschäft so sehr rein, dass du das einfach so reinzieht in einen bestimmten Zweig, dass dieses Rummeandern, dieses Wandern zwischen den verschiedenen Welten einfach aufhört, dass du irgendwo ein Zuhause findest, dass du aufgenommen wirst in den Shows von irgendwas. Letztens dachte ich mir, Förster wäre vielleicht was, weil da hat man so einen ganzen Wald für sich alleine, ist komplett allein und kann mehr oder weniger machen, was man will. Aber kein WLAN und du kannst zwei Striche etsch, das wird dich fertig machen. Ich habe mir tatsächlich die Frage gestellt, ob, also ich meine, jeder, der irgendwie vor der Kamera oder vom Mikrofon ist, hat ja einen gewissen Narzissmus einfach und findet sich zu einem gewissen Grad geil. Und ich habe mir echt überlegt, ob ich einen Beruf ausüben könnte, der sich nicht primär um meine eigene Person dreht. Also jetzt sowas wie ein Arzt, der einfach, wo sich das primär um andere Menschen dreht, der anderen Menschen hilft, der natürlich auch irgendwie was zurückkriegt, aber wo nicht seine eigene anderen Menschen in deinem Beruf? Dadurch, dass du dich jetzt so öffnest in so einem Format, ist das doch oft eine Hilfe. Für viele Menschen auch eine Belastung natürlich, aber das kann ja auch reinigend sein. Störend auch. Aber du bist ja auch, in gewisser Weise geht es natürlich, der Antrieb kommt von dir, aber es geht ja an den Menschen, hilfst du damit natürlich im Alltag. Also wenn die Ärzte zum Beispiel hören das gerne beim Operieren, wahrscheinlich, das Podcast-Ufo, schätze ich mal. Das kann sein. Und das führt zu Problemen, wenn sie lachen müssen. Und vor allem, wenn du so einen Patienten fragst, warum wollen sie denn überhaupt überleben, damit ich die nächste Folge Podcast-Ufo hören kann. Also natürlich der Arzt, man spielt sich ja gegenseitig auch zu. Das ist eine Symbiose. Du warst jetzt in Amerika und wir waren auch wieder nach New York. Wir waren so begeistert. Die ganze BTF ist ja zusammen. Wir waren zum erste Mal in New York. Ja, das war richtig krass für uns einfach. Und jetzt hast du erzählt bei Fest und Flauschig, dass du in Hamilton warst. Wow. Das ist, da habe ich auch erst tatsächlich ich wurde eingeladen von einem Freund und die Karten, also ich habe bei Fest und Flauschig erzählt, dass man die bei TKTS kaufen kann, dass es eine Lüge ist. Ich habe die Karten natürlich nicht selber
gekauft, sondern wurde eingeladen und ich glaube auch nicht, dass man
unter einem hohen vierstelligen
Betrag für eine Karte, dass man da überhaupt
rauskommt. Das ist auf zweieinhalb oder drei
Jahre ausgebucht. In London wird es
ab 2018 aufgeführt und
das ist auch da schon ausgebucht, glaube ich,
das ganze nächste Jahr komplett.
Kommt das auch nach Deutschland? Das macht keinen Sinn.
In Deutschland? Nee, ne? Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, da ist der Markt zu klein für. Und das deutsche Musicalpublikum ist auch einfach so Tatsang. das ganze nächste jahr komplett kommt das auch nach deutschland das macht keinen sinn also ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass da ist der markt zu klein für und das deutsche musical-publikum
ist auch einfach so tatsam ich finde es cool wenn alexander klar aufs oberkörper frei von liana
zu liana schwingt das ist ja auch in amerika ist ja so die basis des dieser dieser kunstform
das ist ja auch im broadway wird ja auch aladdin gespielt und tatsam und so aber die guten stücke
also keine ahnung spamelord ist zum beispiel wirklich ein tolles Stück oder Book of Mormon. Le Miserable. Le Miserable war super. Brillant. Ja. Wir waren das toll. Das war ein toller Abend. Habt ihr das gesehen? Wir haben es gesehen, ja, wir haben es verzeiht. Ich weiß nicht, ob du auch schon mal gesehen hast, aber wir haben es in New York gesehen und es war unfassbar. Ist das wirklich richtig schön? War unglaublich. Die haben gerudert auf der Bühne, als wäre es ein Schiff. Ich dachte mir, es ist unfassbar, weil es ist kein Schiff. Aber ich dachte für einen Moment. Und dann kam ein Haus rein, was so gross war wie ein Haus. Ich merke schon, ihr habt da eine generelle, ich spüre die generelle innere Ablehnung diesem Genre komplett gegenüber. Gar nicht. Das ist ironiefrei richtig cool. Ja, das Schlimme ist ja, die kriegen einen wirklich emotional. Ich sass da auch bei Hamilton und habe auch bei zwei Stücken, genau wie der Rest des Theaters, einfach angefangen zu weinen, weil es so traurig ist und es auch so gut gespielt ist. Ich glaube, vielleicht ist auch die Sprachbarriere, die mich dann so Sachen reininterpretieren lässt, die da gar nicht drin sind, dass ich das nicht so ganz verstehe, aber das war schon wirklich ein bewegender Theateramt und ich höre seitdem auch wirklich rauf und runter diesen Soundtrack. Und die Geschichte von diesem Typen ist einfach so gut, der das geschrieben hat. Das finde ich eine geile, ja, genau, und von Hamilton selber auch eine geile Geschichte. Aber der Lin-Manuel Miranda ist der Komponist und der Der Text da und der Autor des Stück Genau, und von Hamilton selber. Auch von Hamilton, aber der Lin-Manuel Miranda
ist der Komponist und der Texter
und der Autor des Stückes, der hat das
in, ich glaube, sieben oder acht Jahren
selbst geschrieben. Der hat das erst aufgeführt an so einem
Community College
im Süden von
Manhattan, also in so einer offenen Bühne,
in einer staatlichen Bühne, glaube ich sogar,
und ist dann mit der Company irgendwann weggekauft worden
oder zum Broadway gegangen. Und mit denselben Leuten hat er das da zwei Jahre gespielt, wurde dann von Barack Obama ins Weiße Haus eingeladen. Und das sollte eigentlich ein Konzeptalbum, ein Hip-Hop-Konzeptalbum werden. Und dann ist es daraus eben ein Musical geworden. Und alle Leute aus der Company, aus der ersten Besetzung quasi, die zum ersten Mal dabei sind, sind mittlerweile echt Stars geworden, echte richtige Stars und spielen es auch in Sitcoms mit und in Filmen und sowas. Und er hat jetzt, glaube ich, für, er sitzt, glaube ich, gerade an einem Soundtrack für einen Disney-Film. Also der ist auch echt nach oben katapultiert worden. Und da siehst du halt mal, man muss halt nur jahrelang gute Arbeit leisten, dann gelingt das. Das ist das Schöne. Aber er war schön in Amerika, war echt toll, politisch merkt man eigentlich gar nicht, was gerade los ist. Überhaupt nicht. Wirklich nicht. Aber ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, ich war jetzt, vor ein paar Wochen war ich in Orlando. Disneyland? Nee, richtig, nee. Da war die Star Wars Celebration. Ah ja. Du merkst, ich habe keine Freundin. Vor allem ganz kurz, das ist ein großes Missverständnis, dass Leute denken, Star Wars ist ein Nerd-Thema. Das stimmt, das ist ein Multibillionen-Dollar-Franchise, was auf der ganzen Welt jeder kennt. Das ist wie McDonald's. Richtig. Wie McDonald's-Fan sein. Ich bin Fan von McDonald's, am liebsten esse ich, egal wo ich bin, in welcher Stadt, ich gehe mal erst zu McDonald's, ich bin so ein Riesen-Fan, so cool ist das ungefähr. Ich bin so ein Nerd, die Süsslauer-Soße ist richtig lecker. Ja, stimmt schon. Es gibt ja bei McDonald's übrigens neue Soßen, habe ich gehört, man kriegt eine von fünf McDonald's Soßen irgendwie, ob ich... Die Rick and Morty Soße auch oder was? Nein, eine von fünf McDonald's-Soßen kriegt man, wenn man ein McMenü oder sowas kauft. Aber ich glaube, das ist dann so eine grosse Dose für zu Hause. Fun Fact, der neue Junior-Autor von Gute Arbeit, Tarek, genau, sein Onkel, hat, glaube ich, diese Soße für McDonald's entwickelt. Für den Big Tasty. Für den Big Tasty entwickelt. Sausenkoch, Saussier. tarek kennt die personen die eine person kennt die die big tasty soße entworfen hat was eine absolute legende ist war der big tasty das ist der der so richtig ist der mit den zwei mit bacon drei ich auch nicht meine ist der mit dem drei brottschein wo wir gerade jetzt auf den sommer zu gehen und soßen und so ich habe vor vor vielen jahren mir mal vorgenommen als ichangen habe, seid ihr schon in der Kochphase, ihr kocht ja selbst, nee, beide nicht. Nee, gar nicht, gut oral. Genau, also ich habe dann irgendwann angefangen, selbst zu kochen, auch als ich alleine gelebt habe, ganz alleine, und da habe ich dann immer gedacht, das geht jetzt nicht mehr. Und dann habe ich angefangen zu kochen und habe dann festgestellt, dass Grillsoßen tatsächlich, das ist ein Riesenbeschiss, ein riesiger Markt, Leute kaufen sich im Supermarkt Grillsoßen, die sind aber anderthalb Jahre haltbar, die stehen nicht im Kühlregal. Und dann kann man überlegen, was ist eigentlich anderthalb Jahre lang haltbar, ohne dass es im Kühlregal steht. Das ist ganz schlimme Chemie. Und Grillsaucen selber machen ist seitdem einer meiner großen Hobbys. Ganz toll, Soßenbasis mit Apfelmus, mit Joghurt, mit Zucker. Schönen Thermomix auch? Keinen Thermomix. Grillst du die Soßen dann auch mit? Weil ich habe für mich so einen kleinen Durchbruch erlebt, in dem ich gemerkt habe, dass man die Grillsoßen bestenfalls auch mitgrillt. Als Marinade kann man das. Als Glasur und dann wirklich auch wenden und dann immer wieder, dass das wirklich so wie so ein Spare-Rip auch so eine krustige, feucht-weich-krustige Ader da rum hat. Bist du gerade in so einer Jojo-Phase oder bist du gerade wieder ab? Ich bin wieder aufwärts. Ich habe jetzt auch gerade so eine Massephase hinter mir gebracht und da hat mich das auch interessiert. So eine Barbecue-Sauce. Ich habe versucht, Pulled Pork zu machen, das macht ja auch mit so einer Barbecue-Sauce, das wird von außen. Da dauert vor allem ewig völliger Quatsch und dann hast du hinterher so einen zerfleddernden Schweinebraten, weil mehr ist es ja eigentlich nicht. Stimmt. Mit so einer Barbecue-Sausie, muss ich immer wieder einstreichen und so, sehr, sehr aufwendig. Wir sind jetzt umgestiegen auf Yule. Yule ist Nahrungserklärung. Habe ich gehört. Einfach, weil wir, also mittags haben wir auch keine Zeit manchmal einfach, man muss ja so viel schreiben. Vielleicht muss man das den Leuten mal erklären, wie das hier strukturell aufgebaut ist, also die Gute-Arbeit-Crew sitzt in einem Teil unserer Firma. Richtig. Und das Neo-Magazin sitzt in einem anderen Teil der Firma und wir sehen uns eigentlich nie. Das stimmt, das ist wirklich. Außer Florentin war in die Sendung, wir haben uns ewig nicht mehr gesehen. Nee, das stimmt, überhaupt nicht mehr. Das lässt man bei der Wahlnacht, glaube ich. Das stimmt, das lässt man bei der Wahlnacht und Tarek sieht manchmal morgens beim Bäcker, weil der wohnt da hinten in der Nähe, Florentin sieht manchmal in der Sendung, wenn er irgendeinen Auftritt hat, aber eigentlich sehen wir uns fast gar nicht mehr und es hat sich aber rumgesprochen, dass ihr mit so einer komischen Zoll und Grünpampe hier versucht, wenn diese News quasi die Wege gemacht haben, so zwischen der ganzen Ost-Gier-Straße, halb Ehrenfeld ist quasi diese News durchgerutscht, das heißt, es war schon ein Thema offensichtlich in der BDF. Ja, es war ein Thema. Man muss sich auch manchmal der einfach der Lächerlichkeit preisgeben, man muss auch einfach manchmal sagen, ja, es ist lächerlich, aber es ist nun mal Teil von mir. E Eingangsvoraussetzung für den Job ist, dass man das anregend.
Absolut, ja.
Alle Menschen scheissen, alle Menschen sehen unter der Dusche nackt scheiße aus, zumindest die meisten.
Und die, die geil unter der Dusche aussehen, die tun das auch nur bis zum 40. Lebensjahr.
Und mit denen möchte man, solange sie geil aussehen, eigentlich nichts zu tun haben.
Es ist sehr, sehr anstrengend.
Also mit schönen Menschen sich zu umgeben ist sehr, sehr anstrengend.
Es wird immer nur so ein Äpfelchen gegessen, in so einem Salat rumgepiekst.
Und wo findest du meine Brust hängt und so. Alles so Sachen, von denen man sich relativ früh freimachen sollte. Also wenn ihr da draußen überlegt, eine Beziehung einzugehen mit einem schönen Menschen, Finger weg, Finger weg davon. Vor diesem Problem stehen die, glaube ich, aber auch nicht. Unsere Hörer stehen vor dem Problem, mit einem schönen Menschen eine Beziehung einzugehen. Allgemein vor dem Problem Beziehung stehen die eigentlich nicht. Ja, nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich habe mich vorgestern, war ich beim Probetraining zum Fitnessstudio, weil ich dachte, so kann es nicht weitergehen. Wie alt bist du jetzt? 22 bin ich jetzt. Und dann dachte ich mir auch so, na... Wo denn, Neptunbad? Nee, das ist mir viel zu teuer, Health City. Aber wenn, dann mach, wenn, dann gehst du ins Neptunbad, weil dann ist es, dann schmerzt es richtig, wenn du nicht hingehst. Das spürst du, weil das ist diese Fitnessstudio-Impulse, du gehst da hin, machst ein Probetraining,
unterschreibst dann fahrlässig, du hast immer ein Jahr Mindestvertragslaufzeit, das kannst du auch beim Neptunbad machen, da hast du wenigstens noch einen schönen Saunabereich dazu, in einem historischen Ambiente und es kostet halt jeden Monat glaube ich 70 Euro oder sowas. Ich glaube mehr als 100, das ist mehr als 100 Euro, aber es schmerzt dann auch richtig. Katja ist da, weil da wirst du wenigstens von anspruchsvollen Herren wird dir da auf die Scheibe geguckt und nicht von diesen Proll-Assis, die irgendwie in der Fitness-First abhängen oder bei McFit oder so. Ja, ich war dann zum Probetraining da und dann ist leider das Problem eingetreten, dass ich zu spät war und der Trainer dann weg war, was dazu führte, dass sie mich rumgeführt haben und gesagt haben, ja jetzt trainiere halt, so mach einfach mal, weil ich dachte, ich kann das und dann bin ich einfach eine halbe Stunde da rumgelaufen an den geräten habe geguckt was man da genau macht und so getan hat so habe ich das halt schon ewig kenne und jedes gerät in und auswendig kenne und habe dann so ein bisschen was gedrückt und mich dann wieder umgezogen bin gegangen ich habe massiv muskelkater allein davon schon ja ich habe das auch mal gemacht habe mein probetraining gemacht und habe mir auch unterschrieben und habe genau diese diese klassische fitnessstudio falle seitdem bin ich ein riesen für ihr einfach wahnsinnig, ich käme Inlineskates, Inlineskates schön durch die Stadt. Das ist mein Ding. Weil irgendwann legst du wirklich auch dieses Gefühl ab, dass es irgendjemanden irgendwie auch nur, dass du, es ist irgendwann scheißegal, was du machst. Ab einem gewissen Punkt sagen sie, ach guck mal, der Böhmermann ist doch eh egal, wie er rumläuft. Ich könnte wahrscheinlich sogar im Stringtang gar durch die Strasse laufen und alle würden sagen, ja gut, habe ich von ihm erwartet. Und das ist eigentlich sehr, sehr befreiend. Das ist ein Seniorending, bei dem ist auch irgendwann egal, was sie machen. Einfach auch nicht mehr das Prinzip, nicht mehr nach hinten gucken, wenn man rückwärts ausparkt. Das ist so, irgendwann ist es egal, was du machst, irgendwann nimmt sich auch niemanden mehr böse und dann fährst du einfach zurück. So was, irgendwann muss der diese... Ich war heute beim Zahnarzt heute Morgen und ich habe fast einen unfall gebaut in einer parkgarage mich rückwärts rausgefahren tatsächlich rückwärts gang eingelegt und wollte rausfahren und habe dann noch kurz aufs handy geguckt und hat dann einfach gas gegeben und dann bin ich fast einem reingefahren der quasi einmal vorbeigefahren ist der aber gesehen hat dass ich einen rückwärtsgang eingelegt habe und gerade dabei war rauszufahren der aber dann einfach mal nervenkitzel ausprobieren wollte dass an die Nerven kitzeln wollte und mal gucken wollte, wann ich denn rausfahre. Und dann hat er nochmal angehalten, so ein pädagogisches Anhalten, so nach dem Motto, mich dann so böse angeguckt, das war aber so nach dem Motto, das war knapp. Und der hat sich dann auf dem Weg, ich bin dem hinterhergefahren, aus der Parkgarage raus und der hat sich dann in den folgenden zwei Kilometern mehrfach mit Leuten im Straßenverkehr angelegt, sodass ich das Gefühl habe, ich glaube, der war einfach entweder auf MDMA oder halt so ein, keine Ahnung, Mensch mit jetzt in der AfD würde man sagen, Vorfahren vom Balkan, der einfach sich im Straßenverkehr so ein kleines bisschen das holt, was er zu Hause nicht bekommt. Oder er war aber auch im Zahnarzt und hat einfach eine massive Dosis bekommen. Ich glaube, der war tatsächlich bei einer neuen Fitness, beim neuen Fitnessstudio, was er eröffnet wird, neben meinem Zahnarzt gerade. Das ist eine gute Kombination, Zahnarzt und dann direkt Workout. Fitness-Zahnarzt. Das ist nicht schlecht. Zahnärzte sind wirklich eigentlich keine richtigen Ärzte, sind eigentlich so ein bisschen so wie Podcast eigentlich kein richtiges Medium ist, ist eigentlich ein Zahnarzt auch kein richtiger Arzt. Aber ich habe die perfekte Verbindung zwischen Training und Zähnen, ich musste nämlich mal meine Lippen trainieren. Warum? Meine Lippen waren zu schwach.
Meine Lippen waren zu schwach.
Und deine Freundin sexuell zu befreien. Richtig, aber die Zahnheizung hat gesagt, die Lippen sind zu schwach, weil ich hatte
sehr stark deformierte Zähne als Jugendlicher.
Sieht man gar nicht, wie schön war.
Weil ich eine Zahnspange hatte lange Zeit und jetzt, und die hat mir
so erklärt, dass der Mensch ein instinktives
Reflex hat, dass
kein Speichel ausläuft und
normalerweise macht er das, indem er die Lippen zumacht. Aufgepasst, also noch mal für jeden zu Hause, auch mal nachmachen einfach. Lippen zu machen, da läuft es nicht raus. Aber da meine Lippen so schwach waren, hat mein Körper instinktiv die Zunge von hinten noch zwischen die Lippen gesteckt. Und dadurch hat meine Zunge über Jahre, jahrhundertelang hinten gegen meine Zähne gedrückt. Und die Zunge ist ja der stärkste Muskel des Körpers. Das heißt, über lange Jahre haben die einfach die Zähne verschoben, dadurch dass die Zunge und dann musste ich das lernen und dann hatte ich so wie so ein Schnuller im Mund und muss dann immer so so ein Gummiding oben so zusammen drücken. War das eine Logopädie oder war das noch was anderes? Nee, das war Kieferorthopädie, einfach ganz klassisch. Und jetzt muss sie dann so in den Mund nehmen und dann so ziehen und dann mit den Lippen selber dagegen halten, was unglaublich nah an dem Ding ist.
Das habe ich aber auch mal gemacht.
Ich war die krasseste Zahnspange mit diesem Gurt hinten.
Ja, ja, wer hatte sie nicht. Ich war mit den Messdienern in einem Freizeitpark, der kein richtiger Freizeitpark war, so ein B-Freizeitpark, mit dieser Zahnspange und diesem Gurt. Das war der Tiefung meiner Dinge. Du hast sie in der Achterbahn verhängt. Und trotzdem hast du heute einen eigenen Podcast. Wow. Geil. We did it, Florentin. Wir haben es geschafft. Wir sind raus aus dem Sumpf. Schön ist das hier in eurem Büro, es ist ein Podcast. Florentin und Stefan haben ein Podcast-Büro, das war aber ein bisschen lang neu, dass es hier eine neue Räumlichkeit gibt. Die kannte ich noch gar nicht. Wir sind ein bisschen wie ein Einsiedlerkrebs, wir kommen hier immer und nehmen das ein, aber dann sind wir sofort wieder weg. Und was ist hinter dieser Polstertür? Das war meine erste Frage in diesem Raum. Was ist hinter einer Polstertür? Irgendwas, wo man nicht hören darf, was dahinter passiert. Theoretisch, das stimmt ja eigentlich. Wo da drin jemand hören darf, was hier draußen passiert. Was ist es denn? Die Frage, glaube ich, hat sich schon wieder gestellt. Ich gehe einfach mal gucken. Guck mal rein, was da drin ist. Absolut unspektakulär. Da würde ich jetzt auch in meinem prominenten Geschwärm. Ich finde, diese Bücher sind so typisch Ausstattungsbücher. Das ist einfach so ein Klischee-Bücherregal. Ihr müsst die Leute mal ein bisschen an die Hand nehmen. Die wissen ja gar nicht, was ausstattet. Die kennen das Bücherregal in Ausbildung. Ich glaube, wir haben schon auf dem Buch ein bisschen was vorliegt. Ego mit 100 Folgen, wenn man hier sitzt, dann irgendwann werden die Themen rar. Archäologie, Teppiche, einer Herzung, einer Fein. Und warum dauert das so lange, bis es ausgestrahlt wird oder gesendet wird? Das ist perfekt durchoptimiert nach Search Engine Optimization und allem. Ach so, also immer Montag gibt es ein neues Podcast. Ja, Montag, sechs Uhr dreissig, einfach. Morgens? Zack, wenn ihr das Internet hochfährt, dass wir die allerersten sind und dann sofort geklickt werden. Ja, und es gibt es immer am Sonntag, nachts um null Uhr. Das ist die schlechteste Zeit, glaube ich. Nee, aber dann fangen die Hardcore-Leute, hören am Sonntag auch schon. Genau die reichen in der Woche einfach. Genau, und ich glaube, ein großer Teil der Leute hört es morgens auf dem Weg zur Arbeit, am Montagmorgen. Ich habe wahnsinnig Hunger, ich habe nichts gegessen heute. Aber hast du theoretisch, wie lange willst du den Podcast noch machen? Glaubst du, das ist einfach unendlich? Nee, ich glaube, ich finde, das ist, wie man jetzt ja auch mitbekommt, einige Radiostationen haben auch schon, wilde Comedians sich in zweier Kombinationen zusammensetzen lassen, um da irgendwie mal so ein bisschen Menschlichkeit nach 30 Jahren das Formatradios wieder einkehren zu lassen in die öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunkanstalten. Ich glaube, das wird irgendwann die Wortsendung ersetzen. Und in Amerika gibt es Wortradio, gibt es ganze Stationen, wo nur gelabert wird die ganze Zeit. Und ich glaube, genauso wie die Leute gerne QVC gucken, nicht weil sie sich was kaufen wollen, sondern weil sie gerne unterhalten werden oder weil sie gerne dabei sind, wenn Leute reden über Dinge, die sie nachvollziehen können, ist das eine Sache, die, glaube ich, Bestand haben wird. Ich glaube, das wird eher nach oben gehen mit dem Podcast. Die Frage ist halt der Refinanzierung. Ich höre sehr gerne Pod Save America und da finde ich es immer schon sehr erniedrigend, wenn dann die beiden Podcast-Moderatoren anfangen, Werbung zu machen für irgendwelche komischen Internet-Bären-Versand-Handel, square space nature box genau und das finde ich irgendwie nicht so nicht so schön das müsste man irgendwie anders regeln das kann man vielleicht nach vorne oder nach hinten schieben und wenn du dann sponsor findest oder mehrere dieses tragen oder eine plattform dann ist das ich finde es das perfekte medium und eigentlich sollten öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunkanstalten anfangen dass das grossflächige einzuführen. Ich habe früher auch gerne Wortradio gehört, das ist ja im Prinzip nichts anderes. Und je besser das vorbereitet ist, wenn du, keine Ahnung, Physikpodcast hast oder sowas, wo du wirklich auch echt Arbeit in die Vorbereitung steckst und nicht einfach nur so rumlaberst, dann hat es ja auch einen mehr... Ein kleiner Seitenhieb. Genau. Nein, nein, das trifft ja mich auch. Also wir sind ja auch, wir bereiten uns zwar schon vor, also wir telefonieren vorher ein, zweiimal, bevor wir die Sendung machen, damit wir wissen, worüber wir reden. Manchmal klappt das aber auch nicht. Und dann ist es natürlich schon gelabert, aber dann hilft es sehr, dass man sich schon jahrelang kennt und eingespielt ist. Also wir haben ja auch schon weit über, ich glaube, 400 Sendungen jetzt gemacht, fast 500. Das ist nicht schlecht. Wer war in eurer hundertsten zu Gast? Weiß es noch? Keine Ahnung, wir haben wahrscheinlich nicht mitgezählt. Wir haben bei Spotify im Jahr, ich glaube, 45 Sendungen. Und früher sanft und sorgfältig waren auch knapp 45 Sendungen. Und das haben wir vier Jahre gemacht. Also, na gut, nee, sind gar nicht so viel. 300 Sendungen vielleicht, knapp. Aber ich muss nur kurz auf Setmeyer kommen, weil das war schon echt cool, auch so für uns zu sehen. Das war für mich auch cool. Mega. Es wirkte am ersten Moment wie so ein Greenscreen-Effekt, wie so ein Neomagazin-Einspieler. Und da ist sie so, das sieht nicht schlecht aus. Wie der Mann des Lanzabklatscher da. Ganz surreal. Das war ja schon zwei Jahre lang geplant. Also die haben, also no promo shit und so, die haben mich eingeladen, weil es gab mal einen New York Times Artikel über das, was wir machen im Neo Magazin und das war die Varoufakis Sache.
Über die Varoufakis-Sache, genau. Und das hat dann jemand von deren Gästeredakteuren gelesen.
Und da haben die uns, oder mich, ich sage nicht aus Grosskotzigkeit uns, sondern aus falsch verstandener Bescheidenheit,
da haben die mich eingeladen Ende 2015 und dann kam halt die Erdogan-Sache und da hätte ich nach der Erdogan-Sache eigentlich da hin sollen,
hab das dann aber, als wir zusammen in New York waren, da warnt ihr doch auch mit, da hätte ich da eigentlich auch hingehen sollen, da haben wir das relativ kurzfristig abgesagt, weil das wäre der erste öffentliche Auftritt nach der Erdogan-Geschichte gewesen und das fände ich irgendwie, weil das scheiße. Auf der großen Bühne. Ja, das ist aber scheisse, das in Amerika und dann wirklich so Dissidentenmässig dann in Amerika zu erzählen, was scheisse in Deutschland läuft.
Und das fand ich irgendwie unpassend und hab's dann verschoben und dann, weil die natürlich nicht die Reisekosten zahlen, von einem aus deren Sicht natürlich unbekannten Comedien aus Deutschland, von Deutschland nach Amerika. Und ich fliege ja auch nur noch First, ich fliege nur noch First, das macht meinen Rücken nicht mehr mit. Und deswegen musste man das so organisieren, dass ich dann quasi diesen Auftritt nachhole, wenn ich sowieso in Amerika bin, und das war jetzt eben der Fall. Allein da zu sein, das war ganz toll. 30 Rock, also da, wo wirklich auch SNL gedreht wird, auf derselben Bühnebene ist das Seth Meyers Studio. Genau, wir waren da auch sogar, als wir in New York waren alle, da hatten wir Karten für Seth Meyers. Ah, ihr wart da? Genau, wir waren jetzt bei Seth Meyers, das war super. Das hat mir auch besser gefallen als Colbert tatsächlich noch. Wirklich? Ja, ich mag einfach Seth Meyers gern, doch, also habe ich damals auch, ich finde das einfach ein cooler Typ, der war ja auch Headrider von SNL und so. Genau. Ich finde das einfach ein sehr präziser, cooler Typ. Genau, und das ist was, was total faszinierend war und was ich gar nicht gedacht hätte, ich bin da wirklich mit so einem Exoten-Gefühl hingekommen und dachte, ja, was weiss der schon und so und was wir in Deutschland machen, das ist für die ja eher lächerlich. Aber ich glaube, spätestens seit Trump, aber auch in den Jahren davor, das ist schon anders als so vor 20 Jahren. Die nehmen das schon, was wir hier machen oder zumindest was im Neomagazin läuft, was in Europa läuft, das nehmen die ganz anders wahr. Das ist nicht so von oben herab, das war wirklich ganz angenehm, ich will jetzt nicht sagen auf Augenhöhe, das wäre schon so ein bisschen vermessen, der hat natürlich eine grössere Sendung, aber es war zumindest genauso, als würde ich mich jetzt irgendwie mit einem Pierre M. Krause unterhalten, über die gleichen Dinge, wie wir machen die gleichen Sendungen, man redet über dieselben Dinge, man ist in derselben Informationsschleife drin, in dem selben Arbeitsmodus und wir haben uns danach noch zwei Stunden unterhalten und haben noch einen Podcast zusammen aufgenommen, haben da irgendwie noch gequatscht lange und das war wirklich sehr interessant, das mal kennenzulernen. Und ich glaube auch, dass das nicht das letzte Mal war, dass wir uns jetzt gesehen haben. Wie sehr ist da dieser Talk-Teil, ist da vorbereitet, gescriptet, komplett? Total, unglaublich. Also ganz nicht gescriptet, gar nicht gescriptet, aber das ist tatsächlich ganz anders vorbereitet als auch noch bei Lanz oder sowas. Da gibt es ja auch Vorgespräche. Man muss sich das mal vorstellen, die machen 40 Sendungen im Jahr, 40 Sendungswochen im Jahr. Ah, jeden Tag eine Sendung. Jeden Tag eine Sendung, also fünf Sendungen in der Woche mal 40, das sind also 200 Sendungen im Jahr. Wie viele Autoren haben die? Die haben ein Team von 150 Leuten plus das technische Personal, das ist nochmal getrennt. Das technische Personal ist aber auch wirklich so WDR-Style, 60-jährige Kameraleute, die keine Lust haben und so. Das ist alles richtig Oldschool-Technik, die sind bei NBC sowieso im Haus und die nehmen dann auch andere Sendungen auf, die da im Morgenshow und so. Die haben einfach Schichten und werden durchs Haus gereicht. Was total interessant war zu sehen, das sieht man eben nicht, wenn man da als Studiogast ist oder im Publikum sitzt, in diesen Arbeitsräumen. Also die Studio hat eine entsprechende Höhe, Studioräumlichkeiten sind immer höher, weil da oben Lichter hängen und so. Das geht im Rockefeller Center über, glaube ich, vier Stockwerke, das Studio von Seth Meyers. Das heißt also, die Studiohöhe von Seth Meyers wird hinter den Kulissen eingeteilt auf vier Arbeitsstockwerke. Du läufst dann also quasi durch Gänge, die so derart klaustrophobisch eng und niedrig sind. New York. Genau in New York, das heißt der Platz ist teuer, den man da hat. Und die Gänge sind alle so knapp über der Tür, sind schon die Zwischendecken eingezogen. Das sind Gebäude aus den 30er Jahren. Und da hat man noch nicht gewusst, wie viele Kabel man dann später im Jahr 2017 mal braucht, um so ein Fernsehstudio zu vernetzen. Da direkt, ich würde mal sagen, da wo so die Klimaanlage ist, da waren wir hier in diesem Raum, in dem wir jetzt gerade sitzen, also über einem normalen Türrahmen von zwei Metern, vielleicht zehn Zentimeter nach oben, da wird schon diese Zwischendecke eingezogen, du hast das als grosser Mann hast das Gefühl, du stösst dir andauernd den Kopf, es ist sehr klaustrophobisch und nur Leute mit leitenden Positionen haben ein Fenster nach draußen und auch nicht so ein Fenster, sondern ein Fenster von von vielleicht 50 x 50 cm Größe, was man nicht aufmachen kann, weil da unten so eine Klimaanlage drin ist. Es ist wirklich zum Arbeiten sehr, sehr unangenehm. Ganz eng. Und im Writer's Room, ich weiß nicht, wie das... Der Writer's Room bei uns ist im Neo Magazin so, dass wir einen grossen Tisch haben in der Mitte, alle sitzen vor ihren Laptops, aber man guckt sich an.
Und da ist es eben komplett anders. Sie sitzen an der Wand, die Leute sitzen an der Wand und gucken da in ihren Computer rein und wenn sie mit jemandem reden wollen, drehen sie sich in den Raum um.
Ansonsten sehen die nichts anderes als ihren Raum, sind verbunden über Slack, wie wir auch und kommunizieren da miteinander, aber es ist wirklich eine hochkonzentrierte Atmosphäre und dadurch, dass er so viele Sendungen am Stück macht und das alles so geskriptet ist und teilweise sich bei Trump ja auch morgens die Lage, von der am Nachmittag Unterscheide, wenn er aufzeichnet, wird das alles ganz anders als bei uns noch vorbereitet von Leuten, die auch noch eine ganz andere Qualifikation haben. Also da gibt es ja den Beruf des Autors, den gibt es ja bei uns eigentlich nicht. Also das sind bei uns unsere so Typen wie wir jetzt oder ihr oder ich, die irgendwie da reinrutschen.
Und auf einmal ist man dann Autor. Das ist ja da wirklich ein erstrebenswerter Beruf, wo dann Leute aus dem Mittleren Westen kommen und nach New York gehen, weil sie Autor werden wollen für Comedy. Und das ist... Man kann auch studieren da, man kann Comedy Writing studieren. Genau, und das ist das Handwerk, auch das kannst du bei uns höchstens autodidaktisch. Wenn du Glück hast, hast du einen guten Chef irgendwo oder kommst von einem Radiosenderiosender oder bis irgendwo, bekommst du aus einer guten Ecke, wo du das lernen kannst, das gibt es bei uns ja nicht.
Aber das Interview finde ich schon interessant, also vor allem, dass sie das so durchsprechend, das merkt man ja auch oft, dass sie einfach auf Schlagwort reagieren und so Trigger haben.
Ich habe zwei Stunden lang mit dem Redakteur telefoniert. Jeder Gast hat einen Gästebetreuer.
Genau, so ein Segment Producer wahrscheinlich.
Genau, ein Segment Producer und der weiss, er ist jetzt für zehn Minuten in der Sendung verantwortlich, mit allem drum und dran.
Und der hat erstmal mich eingekauft, quasi, hat quasi überhaupt den Kontakt hergestellt, der hat den New York Times Artikel gelesen. Der ist dann auch dafür zuständig, in der Redaktionskonferenz den Leuten zu erzählen, warum die mich einladen sollen. Das hat der alles gemacht, dann hat er ein Vorgespräch geführt mit mir vor einem Jahr. Dann hat er ein Vorgespräch geführt am Sendungstag, um zu gucken, wie die Stimmung ist, mir noch mal mehrmals, also ich glaube dreissig mal zu versichern, wie sehr man sich darauf freut, natürlich so amerikanisch, wie sehr man sich freut, dass ich da vorbeikomme. Und dann hat er wirklich ganz, ganz viele Fragen gestellt und ich habe ganz offen geantwortet und aus diesen Fragen und diesem Gespräch, was wir dann geführt haben, zwei Stunden lang, hat er ein Transkript erstellt mit den wichtigsten Talking Points, die sind wir dann, bevor ich ins Studio reingegangen bin, noch mal zehn Minuten, bevor ich auf der Bühne war, noch mal durchgegangen und dann ist eigentlich alles, was auf der Bühne passiert, ist tatsächlich improvisiert gewesen. Es gab eigentlich nichts, was wir vorher besprochen haben, nur für den Fall, dass es irgendwie nicht unterhaltsam gewesen wäre, hätte Seth Meyers wahrscheinlich diese Talking Points aufgegriffen und ich hätte genau gewusst, das war so eine Art großer Fallblack-Plan, damit die nicht schneiden müssen, damit man als Gast die größte Chance hat, abzuliefern. Das ist einfach ultra professionell, toll für den Gast. Du hast da, ich habe noch was mitgebracht. Was kommt jetzt? Für die hundertste Folge. Noch ein paar Gags aus Amerika. Geil! Das hier sind Elthoid Curiously Strong Minze aus dem, hier darf ich euch einen anbieten, Pfefferminz-Pastillen von Seth Meyers, die aus meiner Garderobe sind. Ich habe alles mitgenommen, natürlich aus Souvenirgründen. Und woran denkt ihr, wenn ihr das probiert, an welcher Situation in eurem Leben? Zahnarzt. Richtig. Schmecken original, wie das Zeug, was man beim Zahnarzt immer draufgeschmückt bekommt. Ich habe heute Zahnreinigung, ihr seid alle, ihr seid noch weiser, noch 30, also irgendein ab 30 wird es, da kommen die Zähne, da kommen dann auf einmal, gibt es dann Zahnprobleme, nochmal, wieder. Wie muss man sich das Publikum vorstellen, gerade im Unterschied zu Läufen? Ich bin unglaublich aufgedreht. Ich fand das so anstrengend, wir waren alle bei Colbert, ich fand das so, ich war danach, ich dachte mir, ich bin echt deutsch, das ist eigentlich einfach. Man war da drin und hat man die ganze Zeit geklatscht und man hat auch die Gags nicht verstanden, weil dann auch ein Politiker da war, den man nicht unbedingt kannte und so ein Nachrichtensprecher, der halt so ein Republikaner war und dann hat man aber die ganze Zeit gelacht und man hat geklatscht und man fand das so krass. Ich finde es als Zuschauer wirklich wahnsinnig erniedrigend, bei so einer Sendung zu Gast zu sein, also im Publikum zu sitzen. Du wirst da wie in so einer Geisterbahn aufgepeitscht und das war bei Seth Meyers auch nicht anders. Die haben einen Warm-Upper, das ist alles total durchgeplant, dadurch, dass wir so eine tägliche Routine haben. Du hast das Warm-Up schon gehört, während du in der Garderobe mit Seth geredet hast und das war wirklich, das war wirklich wie so eine Fabrik eigentlich, eine Unterhaltungsfabrik und die Leute waren wirklich, es waren keine eingespielten Lacher, das war dann auch so mein persönlicher Ehrgeiz, das zumindest ein, zwei Mal hinzubekommen, dass die Leute lachen, am Ende war es sogar noch ein bisschen mehr, das war ganz cool, aber die Leute waren so aufgepumpt und die waren so drauf, das war einfach ein sehr dankbares Publikum. Im Neo Magazin oder in Deutschland allgemein ist das nicht so üblich, dass man Leute dazu quasi zwingt, sich zu lachen, die sie nicht verstehen, das ist bei uns dann doch ein bisschen härter, auf der Bühne zu stehen, du hast nicht die Bereitschaft von den Leuten, dass die so mitgehen. Man hat das Gefühl, man nimmt da die Zuschauer auch so ein bisschen in die Verantwortung, die sagen so, hey, es soll eine geile Show werden, ihr müsst jetzt mitmachen, ihr seid auch mit dafür verantwortlich, dass die geile Stimmung ist, eine geile Show, wenn Deutschland ist halt eher so, ja, mach mal, reagiere ich entsprechend und nicht so. Der Deutsche lehnt sich zurück und denkt, haben auch bezahlt und jetzt entertaine mich mal. Und das ist da tatsächlich anders. Da ist dann das Stockholm-Syndrom greift dann da und die Leute haben Lust mitzumachen. Aber willst du das auch beim Neemagazin so machen in Zukunft vielleicht mit den Gästen, dass du sagst, also... Das machen wir ja schon so, also wir machen das ja schon seit Jahren so. Genau, wir haben ja die Vorinterviews gehabt, aber wir haben ja oft auch gemerkt, dass manche Gäste einfach in Deutschland auch irgendwann, da sind dann auch die Kapazitäten an coolen Gästen, mit denen man halt so viel Zeit, die die Bock haben zu deliveren und so, die nicht da sind aus Probegründen und so, die sind halt einfach kleiner. Ja, also ich meine, die Philosophie ist ja ohnehin schon, dass wir uns, wenn die Gäste Zeit haben und auch mal bitten, dass die Gäste sich Zeit nehmen, dass wir dann auch mal die Gäste proben. Das ist ja immer schon so gewesen, dass wir immer nur Live-Musik machen. Es gibt schon so ein paar Sachen, die wir versuchen anders zu machen, aber ich meine, du kannst ja die Markt nicht ändern und du kannst auch dann mit so einem Augenverdrehen oder mit so einer Frustration da rangehen. Wir sind halt in Deutschland, wir haben eine andere Kulturtradition und das läuft bei uns anders und das ist auch okay so, dass es so läuft und da kann man ja auch mit umgehen. Ich glaube, auf der anderen Seite, wenn Seth Meyers bei uns zu Gast wäre, wahrscheinlich würden die Leute dann in vorauseilendem Gehorsam darüber lachen, dass jetzt ein Amerikaner da ist, obwohl das Witzeniveau ist eigentlich vergleichbar wie bei uns. Das ist alles nicht brillanter als bei uns. Man interpretiert viel rein wegen der Sprachbarriere. Ja, wegen der Sprachbarriere und weil man einfach auch, das ist ja oft bei Witzen so, das habe ich jetzt quasi so, wenn du das 15 Jahre machst, und irgendwann dann jetzt so seit fünf Jahren auch, dass die Leute wissen, dass ich offenbar lustig sein soll, Du gehst manchmal raus und machst gar nichts Lustiges und die Leute denken, dass das jetzt, also vermuten schon, jetzt wird es gleich lustig und sind dann eher bereit, sich zu eröffnen und kennen dich halt und freuen sich, dass du da bist und lachen über Dinge, die eigentlich gar nicht witzig sind. Und das ist natürlich auch so ein Effekt, den du bei amerikanischer Unterhaltung hast. Also dieser Blick nach Amerika und dann heißt es immer, ja, dem ist alles viel besser. Ist es eigentlich nicht so. Also die Inhalte sind eigentlich vergleichbar, die haben einfach eine grössere Routine darin, das zu performen und die sind professioneller tatsächlich, das ist der große Unterschied. Ja, das ist aber auch ein Effekt, den wir auch manchmal merken, dass wenn wir irgendwie einen Sketch raushauen, wo wir einfach sagen, so ja, das hat jetzt nicht hundertprozentig geklappt, der war jetzt nicht so super irgendwie, da lief vieles schief und dann denkt man sich, ja, der ist nur so mittel und dann geht er raus und man merkt, die Leute lieben ihn auch und finden ihn total cool. Dann denkt man sich, okay, man hat nicht diese Verbindung zum Zuschauer, die man sich vielleicht immer wünscht oder vorstellt, sondern es ist irgendwie so ein, ja, die machen damit das, was sie wollen, aber wenn man selber denkt, das ist eigentlich fast noch schlimmer, als wenn man es selber cool findet und die Leute es nicht cool finden, ist dann so, dass man merkt, die Leute machen damit so ihr ganz eigenes Ding und holen sich da was ganz anderes raus, als das, was man da selber reingesteckt hat. Aber, aber da steht mich, ich meine, da bist du ja eh nie gefeit vor. Also das passiert ja sowieso immer, dass du nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad Kontrolle darüber hast, was Leute aus dem machen, was du machst. Und das ist ja das Schöne, dass die quasi Interpretation dessen, was du machst, das gehört ja zum Spaß des Berufs dazu. Und ich finde immer, das Schönste, was mir passieren kann, ist, wenn du eine Nummer machst, wo es einfach tausend verschiedene Meinungen zu gibt. Das ist eigentlich möglichst so relevant, dass die Leute das auch interessiert, was sie für eine Meinung haben.
Aber es ist immer schön, wenn Leute sich da unterschiedlich drüber unterhalten können und Sachen rein interpretieren. Man merkt ja beim Neo Magazin, gerade wenn man es verfolgt, zum Neo Magazin, zu Neo Magazin Royal, dass es irgendwie immer politischer wurde und auch immer mit einer klaren, starken Meinung. Hast du das Gefühl, dass das auch eine Pflicht ist, eine Verantwortung, dass man je mehr Aufmerksamkeit man bekommt,
desto mehr man auch die nutzen muss?
Zum Beispiel habe ich jetzt so ein Angebot
bekommen, dass ich irgendwie bei irgend so etwas
mitmachen soll, wo so eine Minuten Clips
sind, wo jeder erklären muss, warum
man wählen gehen soll. Wo ich mir
immer denke, es ist nicht so mega cool
und jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so, was soll man da groß sagen, warum man
wählen soll, aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich ist der Zweck gut. Hat man eine gewisse Pflicht, das zu machen oder sagt man, nee, ich finde es nicht cool und will es einfach nicht machen? Ja, ich bin da so ein bisschen zwiegespalten. Also ich finde dieses platte Engagement oder so Charity-Geschichten, die man von außen bekommt, immer schwierig und ich lehne eigentlich auch alles ab, weil ich finde, das muss aus eigenem Antrieb sein. Das heißt nicht, dass ich jetzt so nichts mache. Ich finde das auch, also das ist nur meine persönliche Meinung, ich finde das auch persönlich schwierig, damit hausieren zu gehen und versuche das so wenig wie möglich zu machen. Wir haben einmal so einen Weihnachtszirkus mit Olli Schulz und Spotify gemacht, wo wir dann die Einnahmen gespendet haben, das war auch mit Ansage. Und das war jetzt immer so eine Ausnahme. aber ansonsten versuche ich auch die sachen die ich so mit dem ganzen vielen podcast geld oder diesem ganzen vielen zdf was man so verdient oder was man irgendwie da ist ja also ab einem gewissen ich sage immer so ich brauche um glücklich zu sein brauche ich nicht mehr als sieben millionen euro jeder cent darüber wird gespendet und ich finde das das mache ich gerne privat und halte das für mich auch gerne privat und bin mit so Engagement von außen immer sehr vorsichtig, weil die Motive immer ganz unterschiedlich sind, warum Leute was machen. Das kann dann irgendwie ein Kumpel sein, der bei der UNESCO arbeitet oder bei UNICEF oder eine alte Freundin oder eine, mit der man mal was hatte, die jetzt irgendwie beim Deutschen Roten Kreuz im Blutspendedienst eine tolle Aktion startet und da irgendwie noch jemanden kennt von früher und so. Das sind alles so viele Motive. Ich suche mir dann gerne meine Zwecke selber aus. Und man hat ja selber in seiner Biografie, ist man an Punkten gewesen, wo man gesehen hat, das und das finde ich gut, das und das finde ich toll, das und das möchte ich unterstützen. Und das finde ich ganz gut, wenn man das dann auch wirklich so subjektiv, wie es eben ist, auch dann später weiterhält. Aber ich finde schon bei grösserer Aufmerksamkeit und bei grösserer Reichweite with great power comes great responsibility. Das stimmt schon. Ich glaube, die schlimmste Situation, die ich je in Verbindung mit dir hatte, Jan, war, als aus meinem privaten Kreis jemand auf mich zugekommen ist, der gesagt hat, ja, ich habe da so einen Freund, der hat jetzt eine schwere Krankheitsdiagnose bekommen und wir wollen ihn so ein bisschen aufmuntern und da wollen wir so eine Party machen und da auch so ein Video machen
mit so Grußclips von vielen Prominenten.
Und könntest du nicht bitte mal den Jan
fragen, ob der nicht für den
todkranken Marcel eine Nachricht. Und ich hatte
solche Gewissensbisse, weil ich wollte natürlich
dich nicht nerven mit sowas, weil das ist natürlich
nervig und dann sagt man so
ja und dann macht er noch einen Gag und so, aber ich dachte mir so
ich kann das Ding jetzt auch nicht antun, wenn das ein großer
Wunsch ist und es war so furchtbar, weil
ich war so gefangen zwischen diesen zwei Idealen.
Was hast du denn daran gemacht, ich habe mich daran nicht mehr, hast du mich gefragt?
Nee.
Hast du mich nicht gefragt?
Und ich weiß nicht, ob so...
Ist er gestorben und dann...
Ja, er ist tot, ohne jemals von Jan Böhrmann sein Heil bekommen zu haben.
Nein, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber ich war so, ich wusste nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ja, also bei solchen Sachen ist es tatsächlich auch so, das ist manchmal tagesformabhängig, es ist aber eigentlich auch generell so, dass ich das versuche nicht zu machen. Nicht, weil ich jetzt ein Menschenfeind bin, sondern ich finde, wenn man das einmal macht, muss man es dann bei allen machen. Man macht einen Fass auf. Man macht einen Fass auf, es wird dann sehr selektiv und es wird, und ich finde das, ich meine das ist ja wahrscheinlich, also bei mir ist es zumindest so, aber ich vermute auch mal auch ähnlich, es ist ja, also ich verleide jetzt nicht darunter, dass ich zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit habe und bin auch nicht auf der Suche nach, brauche diese Anerkennung dann auch nicht oder diese Art von persönlicher Befriedigung, die ziehe ich da jetzt nicht so sehr draus, also ganz aus egoistischen Gründen mache ich das jetzt nicht, ich bin jetzt keiner, keine Ahnung, der grossen Spass daran hat, sich selber auf Selfies von anderen Leuten zu sehen Fotos von sich selber an die Wand hängt. Und ich finde das, weil ich selber eben weiß, dass es eigentlich ein normaler Job ist, der nur mal zufällig von Leuten eben gesehen wird, persönlich auch nicht ganz so doll, dass ich immer denke, also ich weiß, dass das ein normalerer Job ist für mich selber, als die Leute denken, dass es ist. Und deswegen finde ich das dann auch immer, kann ich zwar verstehen, warum Leute das gut finden oder das eine tolle Idee finden, mit mir ein Foto machen zu wollen oder für die Hochzeit mal was von mir eingesprochen zu bekommen. Oder von William. Aber ganz ehrlich, so geil bin ich nicht, frag doch mal irgendjemanden, der geilere Sachen macht. Und ich glaube auch, wenn man irgendwie eine Krankheitsdiagnose bekommt und am nächsten Tag kriegt man eine Grussnachricht von Jan Böhrmann, denkt man sich, okay, es dauert einfach nicht mehr lange, mir geht es wirklich schlecht, wenn jetzt schon Jan Böhrmann einschreiten muss und mir helfen muss. Also liebe Grüße, ich mache das eigentlich, also wenn ich nicht anders kann und wenn jemand vor mir steht und mir das sagt, dann sage ich immer ja. Aber wenn ich das irgendwie vermeiden kann, versuche ich das nicht zu machen. Nee, also ich natürlich schreibe ich Leuten zurück, die lange Briefe schreiben, also bei Fest und Flausch kommen ganz, ganz viele sehr, sehr lange Br lange Briefe und auch sehr emotionale Briefe von schlauen Leuten, die noch nie irgendwem Sachen geschrieben haben. Ja, das haben wir auch immer, so Depressionen, so Leute, die dann hilft denen. Nee, gar nicht, ganz, ganz positiv, also Leute, die sich dann bedanken dafür, was man für so einen Job macht und so, das finde ich dann wirklich sehr rührend und sehr nett. Und wann immer ich Zeit habe, schreibe ich dann auch wirklich persönlich zurück, da ist aber dann tatsächlich Faktor Zeit, das geht einfach nicht. Also ich würde sonst wirklich beschäftigt sein nur mit dem Zurückschreiben und dem Netten zurückschreiben. Weil wenn ich zurückschreibe, würde ich auch nett zurückschreiben. Ich habe einfach eine Autoresponse eingestellt. Oder einfach so ein paar Default-Todesnachrichten so. Hoffentlich geht es dir bald wieder besser. Es gibt dieses Bot von so einem Kopenhagener Startup, die checken, wie du schreibst bei Facebook und dann übernehmen die quasi die Kontrolle über deinen Account und fangen dann an so zu schreiben wie du und die checken auch genau, wie du Freunde nennst, bei welchem Spitznamen und übernehmen dann deinen Duktus und deinen Posting-Rhythmus und schreiben dann einfach für dich. Das wäre doch was für dich vielleicht. Ja, ich glaube, ich kriege das irgendwie anders mit Menschen. Ich löse das mit Menschen nächstes Mal.
Kurz noch zum Thema, wie das deutsche Publikum war. Wir haben einen Clip neulich mal irgendwie gefunden, ein alter, vielleicht kennst du den noch, Bitcoins for Africa, haben wir damals gemacht. Und da haben wir geguckt für Recherchezwecke, weil wir einen Sketch machen wollen, der zufällig genauso ist. Der Clown wollte. Und tatsächlich, vor allem war das so lustig, du hast es anmoderiert, diesen Clip, und die Publikumsreaktion, die in Amerika bahnbrechend wäre, Leute würden ausrasten, war in Deutschland so. Die uns den Rest des Jahres scheißegal sind. Ein Mann am Publikum hustet ein. Ja, naja, gut, aber die Leute... Aber das ist schon sehr lustig. Schweigen und ein Mensch hustet ganz laut. Aber das ist doch... Ich finde das ein schönes Bild. Ich finde, man kann dem Publikum keine Schuld geben. Man kann den Leuten... Das ist diese Mentalität, auf die Bühne zu gehen und den Leuten, die da sind, die Schuld dafür zu geben, dass die Halle nicht ausverkauft ist.
Das ist halt, so ist es halt, da musst du einfach mit leben.
Ich finde das nicht schlecht, aber einfach ein lustiger Tempel von dem.
Ich glaube, wir sind an einem Punkt angelangt, so Entertainment-Entwicklungsevolutionsmässig in Deutschland, wo bei einem kleinen wichtigen Teil in der Unterhaltungsbranche die Erkenntnis gereift ist, dass tatsächlich das komplett professionelle Verhalten und der komplett professionelle Umgang mit Unterhaltung oder zumindest Fernseher oder Rundfunkunterhaltung im weitesten Sinne, würde ich das jetzt mal auch hier dazuzählen, dass das einzige, was funktioniert langfristig und was irgendwie Erfolg bringt, das Professionalisieren davon ist und dass man sich an gewisse Dinge hält und dass man eben gewisse Dinge vorbereitet, dass man Backups einzieht, dass man Sicherheitsnetze aufspannt, dass man Gästen das Bewusstsein einschärft, dass sie abliefern müssen und dass sie selber ein Interesse daran haben sollten, dass das gut wird und dass sich Geschichten zurechtlegen, wenn sie als Gast in eine Sendung kommen zum Beispiel, dass es für Bands cool ist, wenn sie live spielen, bei uns jetzt im Neo Magazin mit einem Orchester zusammen. Wir hatten jetzt Flair zu Gast letzte Woche und er hatte wirklich Tränen in den Augen hinterher. Zum einen, weil er Angst hatte vor mir, glaube ich, und mein, dass ich gerade unglaublich ein Trizeps habe. Aber auch, weil er mit einem Orchester, mit einem 15-köpfigen Orchester gespielt hat, mit echten Musikinstrumenten und die seine Instrumentals so gespielt haben, als klängen sie quasi, als wären sie aus dem Computer, aber halt mit echten Instrumenten. Und das ist wirklich ein beeindruckendes Gefühl, wenn hinter dir 16 Mann mit Instrumenten stehen, die das Stück spielen. Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz, das sind so, so, wir versuchen im Neomagazin, solche Sachen irgendwie zu bewahren und zurückzuholen. Ich würde es gut, wenn du das Flair jetzt so ein Softie gemacht hast. Nein, das wäre dann wirklich Orchesteralbum anplagt aufzunehmen. Nein, das muss ja gar nicht, also du kannst ja mit einem Orchester oder mit so einem sechzehnköpfigen Orchester, wie wir das da drüben haben, kannst du alles spielen. Es klingt alles so wie aus dem Computer und nur halt mit echten Instrumenten, also noch ein kleines bisschen besser und ein kleines bisschen echter und ein bisschen beeindruckender, das live zu hören. Und ich finde, solche Sachen zu bewahren und solche Sachen zu kultivieren und zu entwickeln, das ist so ein bisschen auch so einer unserer Jobs oder das, was wir uns so versucht haben wenn wir sind öffentlich rechtlich wir kriegen geld von allen und wenn schon leute unsere sendung scheiße finden das ist ja auch okay dann wollen wir
versuchen zumindest eine struktur aufzubauen leute ranzuholen die irgendwie versuchen so viele
autoren wie möglich durchzuschleusen und leute irgendwie die nie geschrieben haben oder leute die
nie irgendwie da bock darauf hatten beim fern zu arbeiten, da ranzuholen und denen zumindest die Möglichkeit zu geben.
Ja, danke nochmal.
Ja, nein, aber das ist...
Auf jeden Fall.
Und es gibt, ich weiß, ich fand es bei 1Live war ich total dankbar, da hatte ich zwei ganz tolle Comedy-Chefs, die mich da als Praktikant aufgenommen haben und ich fand es immer toll.
Der Ulf wahrscheinlich.
Ulf, Polmeier genau und Henning, also es war eigentlich Henning Bornemann und Markus Hennig, mit denen ich später auch ein Autorenbüro hatte, und die einfach da einen relativ hohen Standard hatten und die auch ihre Regeln hatten, wie wir zu gut sind, und das einfach, und bei Schmidt zu arbeiten war auch genauso, auch der hatte, und der hat immer noch ganz klare handwerkliche Dinge, bei denen der, wurde zuerst darauf achtet, wo er Witze die Qualität von Witzen misst. Und das kann man leider in Deutschland nur autodidaktisch lernen. Und ich glaube, die Möglichkeit zu schaffen, dass das möglichst viele Leute sehen, dass das eigentlich nichts anderes ist als ein normaler Job, den man dann, wenn man ihn konsequent ausführt, dann auch dazu führt, dass man ihn auch gut ausführen kann. Das ist auch so ein bisschen einer der Jobs, also jetzt beim Autorengeschäft. Aber eine zum beispiel eine ausstattung oder ein kostümfundus aufzubauen und jemandem die möglichkeit zu geben eigenverantwortlich ein lichtkonzept zu erstellen der das sonst nirgendwo machen könnte ist halt auch super und das ist wirklich das beeindruckende bei allen anderen selbstlob selbstlob oder so aber struktur oder es ist lobt der eigenen struktur aber was ich nirgendwo anders so kennengelernt habe, ist, dass die Leute, die hier irgendwie den Hut auf haben für Licht oder für Ton oder für irgendwas, dass die dann so eininvolviert sind und so mitmachen können, wie hier in dem Laden ist schon. Das ist auch cooler als bei Seth Meyers, wo dann einfach die Kameramänner halt diese... Aber da gab es die Prozesse ja auch mal. NBC-Männer. Da gab es die Prozesse ja auch mal, irgendwann als das erfunden wurde Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir nochmal die Möglichkeit haben, losgelöst von irgendwie ZDF oder WDR, nochmal uns so ein Medium neu zu erschließen. Das ist eigentlich immer eine Chance eigentlich, wenn man es anders macht. War bei Brainpool in den 90er Jahren ja auch nicht anders. Die haben auch damals neue Sachen gewagt für Deutschland. Das ist alles, wir sind auch nur ein Teil einer Evolutionskette und irgendwann kommen dann Leute, die noch cooler sind. Irgendw man stellt ihr dann irgendwelche 20-Jährigen ein und die sagen dann irgendwann in 10 Jahren, geht mal weg, weil ihr seid ihr alt. Muss man ja auch ehrlicherweise sagen, auch dass, wenn man sich nicht irgendwann so einen Grand-Seniur-Status erarbeitet, ist man irgendwann auch weg vom Fenster. Das gehört eben auch dazu, mit Würde, wenn es geht. Ich würde mir jetzt gleich was zu essen holen. Ja, gerne, wir sind sehr dankbar, dass du die hunderte Folge mit uns bestritten hast. Ja, das war so, ich dachte, das wäre jetzt das Vorgespräch erst, aber wir haben es auch schon aufgenommen. Wirklich? Ja, wir können das nehmen. Was nehmt ihr denn, Audition zum Aufnehmen oder was nehmt ihr? Audition, ja, wir legen noch ein paar lustige Soundeffekte drunter und dann kann das so raus. Wir schneiden unsere Sätze lustiger um, dass die Pointe immer hinten steht zum Beispiel.
Ah, okay.
Das ist aber ein sprachliches Ding in Deutschland.
Das ist das Schwierige.
Das stimmt.
Aber auf der anderen Seite haben wir dafür, wo wir sprachlich den kleinen Nachteil haben,
den selbst auferlegten Nachteil, dass wir einfach nicht radikal genug sind.
Also diese ganze Sprache und dieses Vulgäre ist absolut angloamerikanischer Standard.
Alles, was lustig ist, alles, was Leute irgendwie zum Lachen bringt, ist erlaubt. Ist nun mal so. Absolut. Das ist fucking richtig. Auch selbst dann benutzt man in Deutschland auch immer noch Anglizismen oder englische Wörter. Es ist verdammt richtig. War jetzt eigentlich gar nicht, wir haben jetzt nicht so einen lustigen Podcast aufgenommen. Wir sind in der Richtung hinter den Kulissen. Ja, das stimmt. Aber auch interessant. Müsst ihr aufpassen, dass Ingmar Stadelmann und Lugumokritsch nicht demnächst euch hier dem Rang ablaufen. Wo seid ihr eigentlich auf der Podcast Top Ten? Die Charts, gute Frage. Wir sind jetzt aus Comedy rausgeflogen. Warum? Wir sind nicht mehr Comedy, wir sind jetzt Bildung. Bildung? Gestern waren wir bei Comedy, heute morgen sind wir wieder reingekommen, dank dir glaube ich.
Komische Sache. Ne, ich glaube,
bei Spotify hören uns jetzt mehr
Leute, deswegen sind wir bei euch nicht mehr so
oben in den Charts. Also wir sind
zwar noch da zu hören, aber die meisten hören sich schon
bei Spotify. Wir sind gar nicht bei uns, wir sind exklusiv nur bei Spotify.
Wir sind nur bei Spotify, ja. Wir laufen dann auch überall.
Das ist ein großer Vorteil. Aber wir sind
ein Anker-Podcast, wir sind quasi
sowas. Und der Money-Podcast, wie wir im Internet, weil ich meine, wenn der exklusiv läuft, ist das natürlich das andere. Ja, weiß ich nicht, aber Geld, wir machen es nicht viel Geld. Das ist auch wirklich die Geschichte, die wir immer wieder erzählt haben und ich immer wieder erzählt habe, ist auch wirklich wahr. Ich wollte, fand Spotify immer schon gut und wollte damals, da habe ich mal geguckt, was es sonst noch so gibt, da muss man immer beim Radio arbeiten und man hatte so das leichte Gefühl, dass eventuell da mal vielleicht so eine kleine Strukturreform oder so ein Bewusstseinswechsel vielleicht ganz gut tut, der ja übrigens jetzt auch eingesetzt hat, also muss man auch mal sagen, also unser Weggang hat da glaube ich schon so ein bisschen was bewegt und auf einmal wird dann Wert darauf gelegt, dass eben eins live macht einen Podcast mit zwei wilden, frechen Jungen, die sich tolle... Ich denke, das werden Scherz die ganze Zeit. Das machen die wirklich? Ja, mit Luke und Ingmar Stadelmann.
Liebe Grüße.
Da habe ich mit großem Erfolg. Und Stefan
Ligemey und Sarah Kuttner. Auch liebe Grüße,
habe ich noch nicht hören können, leider keine Zeit zugehabt,
aber bestimmt auch toll. Bestimmt.
Und sicher ein
auf ein
stabiles Fundament und lange Sicht angelegtes
Projekt. Was hörst du so für Podcasts?
Speziell so wahrscheinlich in Gesprächen. Ja, also Pod Save America und The Daily eigentlich von der New York Times hauptsächlich. Aber auch sehr regelmäßig, also vom Einschlafen eigentlich immer. Und es werden auch viele zum Einschlafen, was ich komisch finde. Ich finde das Prinzip im Schlaflachen immer ein sehr lustiges Bild. Ja, aber es wird ja selten gelacht, das ist das Gute. Das stimmt, das gute Branche. Keine Gefahr. Gut, ja, vielen Dank. Thanks for having me. Darf ich euch noch ein Älterheits-Strong mit anbieten? Vielen Dank. Es schmeckt auch so amerikanisch, man weiss gar nicht, warum. Das ist einfach absolut künstlich. Diesen Geschmack gibt es nicht in der freien Natur. Gut, ja dann, vielen Dank fürs Dasein. Vielen Dank, liebes Podcast-UFO, auf viele weitere hundert Folgen. Wir freuen uns. Und liebe Grüsse auch an das Pizza-Ufo.
Habt ihr schon erwähnt, das ist eigentlich der Herr.
Wir müssen dringend auf... Es ist eine Legende.
Gut, wir heben ab, macht's gut. Tschüss.
Ciao, wir heben ab.